when you take a look at that era that
steps out at your 4.11 he's had a couple
of rough outings but increased velo the
last couple of outings have been really
good here is jesse winker
watch this strike three there that was
just like winker did there yeah that was
a really that was a good pitch to to
give credit now eugenio suarez this is
kind of the player of 2021 when we talk
about the three true outcomes right
that's true the walk the strikeout the
home run
and there's a strikeout to end the top
of the first inning from eric lauer wade
miley's turn he's not your usual suspect
not a hard thrower but he mixes the ball
in and out changes speeds he's been
around for a long time keeps the defense
on their toes keeps the game at a good
pace he's a fun guy to play behind
there's a punchy to start the game way
that he gets the ball and gets right
back up there he kind of lulls you to
sleep a little bit and then he quick
pitches with a changeup to get you off
balance here what a great job of
pitching micelle garcia has been a
tremendous player for the brewers
breaking ball chopped over to short
one to india on to first base they
turned two help wade miley get out of
the first inning on skate cincinnati in
milwaukee the mlb game of the week live
on youtube first pitch swinging for
artistitis aquino shallow right field
abby garcia come in that's a can of corn
for him shortstop kyle farmer
farmer sends the 2-0 on the right center
field i'll be giving chase at the track
and he puts the bullet up to make the
grab
good ride there from farmer but no harm
for that man eric lauer all right wade
miley can help your own cause here
chops one over two some redemption there
at the hot corner and he gets smiley
who's hustling down the line we'll face
tyrone taylor to lean things off
that's a really good pitch from wade
miley to hand tyrone taylor a seat
start at second here's the defensive
alignment for cincinnati behind wade
meyer will slow roller over to india at
second just a bit outside nevada but he
can handle it manny pina
oh see that hand he's not right he's not
right now you saw it on that swing that
reaction there is something wrong with
manny pina here's jesse winker winker
struck out looking in the first one of
two strikeouts for lauer in that opening
frame
swinging a tapper hit towards lauer
he'll field it on the second hop
flip lightly over to kesten hero two
quick outs
a couple of quick outs for lower you'd
be wondering if nick castillos might be
taking a pitch here too you don't want
to him
swinging a drive
into right field just in front of the
track garcia comes in
good old-fashioned pitchers duel so far
first three innings nothing doing just
one hit a piece
the o2 pitch grounded over to williams
at short and bottom is retired 0-1 now
to kyle farmer flew out in the second
inning oh one coming
swinging a pop-up
shallow left center out willy adams
infield fly called for the very last
moment by john libka williams made the
catch anyway here's tucker barnhart and
a ground ball under the glove of the
third baseman urias his last time up two
on two out
sends it into left field
tucker barnhart
gonna start the scoring
bringing home suarez throw back to third
gets aquino
but one nothing cincinnati after four
here's avasail garcia
3-2 little looping one hop liner to the
shortstop farmer going to his left
gloves and throws out garcia two men are
out of the fourth inning
ground ball to short farmer has it up
with it throw in time and taylor's out
that's another one two three inning on
the mound for wade miley's retired seven
straight there's jonathan india base hit
his first time up
[Music]
jonathan india is a fun baseball player
i i just love how he's turned it on here
for the cincinnati reds and he gets on
base
once again you're the one out single one
out walk here in the fifth so now a
runner in scoring position for the reds
a chance to add to their one-nothing
lead castiano's chance to do some damage
here
sent into center field taylor
gonna come in
and there's out number two now two outs
for joey bottom
two two swung on a miss a big punchy
from rower who celebrates it with a clap
for himself
peterson bounced out his first time up
two strikes and coming back swinging a
one hopper hit to short off balance
throws gonna be
late for peterson
and he's got an infield base up
you go deep off jacob degrom pena
laces one to the left side the toolboard
here in the fifth for milwaukee and now
number nine spot in the order of the
pitcher eric bauer
i would not pinch it i'm bunting him
over i know bunts aren't a thing but
there he does perfect
[Applause]
i'll tell you what jonathan india what a
terrific play and that's a nice play too
by wade miley
not sure what bunt play was on but wade
miley a little late getting over to the
scene there he kind of threw a
change up to first base and jonathan
indian well we've seen him make a couple
of nifty plays around second base but
this this potentially saves a run second
and third now for milwaukee luis hudias
as
that has skied into right center field
castiano's
calling off aquino
to retire the side his big guns in the
bullpen are coming off back-to-backs and
yes the pitch counts and those outings
were not necessarily high but if lauer
is going the way he is i'm only giving
up the one run and he can help out the
pen a little bit
[Applause]
barnhart
lifted the left right at christian
yelich
one run separates them tonight as we say
hello to miguel sanchez who relieves
eric lowery and wade miley is leading
off so you want miley to go as deep as
he can into the ball
handcuffing these guys
rope to right field hustling to second
base
and the weight starter has a lead off
double the throw bounces away miley
running to third he slides in safely
heads up play get in the tank
get on the tank get him some oxygen look
at the reds player they all want to take
a laugh way to go wade in scoring
position for jonathan india
sanchez bounces back with a big
strikeout of jonathan india this is a
big bad bad for winker so the second run
of the game for the reds 90 feet away
winker after a battle on the 11th pitch
ropes it down the line into right field
miley will trot home
waker has extra bases the reds have a
two-nothing lead back for the bottom of
the seventh inning it's now a two-run
ball game that's chase peterson still
facing wade miley and peterson
hits it hard
bounces out of the reach of aquino he's
going to hustle over to second base
sliding in
but he's out
jesse winker in left field
to jonathan india applying the tag
manny pina
hit to the left side farmer ranging to
his right throws back to his left
and gets pena
outstanding defensive work in the
seventh inning here from the cincinnati
reds
reyes pulled the hands in
lifted to left field
easy play for jesse winker wade miley is
back out there for the eighth inning got
left on left here with miley against
christian yelich yelich represents the
tying run the 3-2 pitch
slapped to the left side
what a range
to second
they cannot turn the double play but
still a great play from eugenio suarez
wow they're gonna is it interference
base runner interference the call check
out this slide going into second base if
it was a late slide wade miley he
started the game david bell is giving
him a chance to finish it
miley's 104th pitch
laced by avi garcia
a lead off double for the milwaukee
brewers
so a tip of the cap
to wade miley an outstanding performance
for him eight shutout innings the reds
going to the bullpen tying run at the
plate rowdy teles
the 2-2
swung on and miss hembree
strikes out teles jase peterson
[Applause]
paint well with the help of a call
a few inches off the plate two outs
tying run at the plate and a slugger and
omar nirvaya's digging in
the 0-2
strike three
reds win